[Music]
[Applause]
Brian Fitzpatrick Thursday night
football analyst of course former NFL
quarterback you can catch him and the
entire Thursday night football crew on
Prime video this fall good to see you
bud how you doing how's the beard
beard is uh actually combed this morning
so hopefully it looks good for you yeah
I like that do you oil it
not much no I am pretty it's pretty low
maintenance maybe a little maybe a
little blow dryer every now
when's the last time you were
clean-shaven
years and years my kids will not let me
do it and I don't know I'm afraid I
don't know what's under there right now
I have a paycheck under there you
wouldn't even know it as big as that
thing is all right
um the schedule released last night I it
can you be an interesting team but be a
bad team
yeah I think so I mean I I've got the
schedule printed out here one of the
ones I was looking at November 9th
Carolina Chicago you know which as we're
going through the games I'm looking at
it thinking gosh uh but you know by
November
we've got the number one pick that's
going to be playing we've got Justin
Fields who I think everybody's looking
to improve this year and all of a sudden
you've got an intriguing matchup of
quarterbacks that you know maybe the
initial look at that game I was thinking
ah you know we'll see but and even being
in Chicago that time of year is going to
be great too
but how excited would you be when you
were playing
when the schedule came out
uh it depends on what team I was playing
for because usually it was gosh we're
playing at one o'clock every single week
so I think you know I I think catching a
Thursday night game a Sunday night a
Monday night that was always the
excitement was being able to play in
front of your peers uh but yeah you know
one o'clock makes for a lot of uh
dinners at home with the family on the
home games but would you rather Play If
I said you could play a one o'clock or
you could play in the evening
as a player uh I know you said you want
to play in front of you know the biggest
audience there
but as far as routine and schedule uh is
it easier to play a day game than a
night game as far as you know seeing
things and atmosphere all that yeah so
so I think yes being in a normal routine
of every week one o'clock whether you're
traveling or you're playing a home game
that's easier for players uh that being
said everybody wants those night games
because they know what comes with that
eyeballs come with that that means that
the league views you as a team that has
a chance to be legitimate and you've got
these teams obviously the Jets this year
they're going to have to adjust because
with the Aaron Rodgers factor I mean a
lot of those guys they haven't really
played any Prime Time games uh the last
few years in their young career so it's
going to be an adjustment for them but
then you've got Patrick Mahomes and Josh
Allen those two teams in Kansas City and
buffalo are so used to okay we're gonna
have five or six a year
I'm not sure why the Chargers have six
Prime Time games I understand Buffalo
and Dallas and Kansas City
well yeah I mean I don't I don't need to
explain to you that you know the LA
Market obviously but also Justin Herbert
I think there's so much Intrigue around
him and you know you take Justin Herbert
who has had multiple coaches now and you
insert Kellen Moore who's led the
highest scoring offense the last few
years in Dallas I think there's a lot of
intrigue around that team and you know I
would say uh it would be an
understatement to say that they
underperformed last year with the hype
and the expectation of what their
defense was supposed to be with all the
new additions last year but I'm thinking
why not Cincinnati playing six they have
four I mean Joe burrow
I
mean you got you got an interesting team
there
um what else was I Baltimore with Lamar
Jackson maybe not
um
but I well
yeah I'll say this though with so we
actually have Baltimore Cincinnati this
year
um I think everybody every year now
wants to see
um Kansas City Cincinnati Buffalo
Cincinnati if it happens to be that
they're matching up but this Baltimore
Cincinnati game I think with Lamar
Jackson there are question marks because
of the injuries and what's happened the
last few years but I'm really excited
about what he's going to do this year a
the contract stuff is behind us so
that's not going to be in the back of
his mind if he's nicked or ding you know
he's going to be a football player he's
going to play through it but Todd monkin
a guy that I played for in Tampa Bay and
some of the weapons that they've given
Lamar I think that offense it is going
to be very intriguing this year to see
where they can go
um so to be able to have a matchup for
us like Baltimore Cincinnati uh that's
one of the ones you know if you're
circling your favorite game on Thursday
Night Football that's one of the ones I
think a lot of people would Circle I saw
where Green Bay has five Prime Time
games and I know there's a great fan
base
but and Minnesota has five
I don't know if people are tuning in to
watch Minnesota you'll tune for the
Curiosity with Jordan love but I don't I
don't know if those are
interesting teams
yeah so the Green Bay stuff you know we
have them week four which I'm very happy
we have them early because there is a
lot of intrigue yes there's a lot of
intrigue about Jordan love and what this
team is going to do but I also think
you're gonna see I mean coach leflore
we're gonna see what kind of Coach he is
you know because there's no more Aaron
Rodgers and I think you rely so much on
your veteran quarterbacks you take it
for granted sometimes and so for Aaron
Rodgers to hold that place together for
as long as he did there is Intrigue but
as they let's say that they get off to a
bad start and start losing games that
Intrigue is going to wane so week four
Green Bay we have Green Bay uh Detroit
looking forward to it I'm glad it's not
week 16.
how much does the veteran quarterback
help a rookie quarterback or is supposed
to help a rookie quarterback a lot uh
really just the approach to the game the
NFL game is so different the study
habits have to be so different the way
that you take care of your body the
routine that you get into all that stuff
being able to learn from a guy that's
done it and I would just take the
example of Carolina really smart move to
bring in somebody like Andy Dalton uh
who's done it Josh McCown on the
coaching staff who's done it so now
we're going to try to groom this young
guy and you have a couple willing
participants there that are going to say
look this is what I've done in my career
this is what's been successful what
hasn't you've got to choose your own
path but it's really important because
it's the toughest position to play and
you don't want a guy out there just
winging it trying to figure it out on
itself but how difficult is it to groom
the guy who's going to take your job
I just think there's there's certain
guys you just you know I was in a
position especially late in my career
that was my role my role was I'm gonna
try to find a place you know every year
it seemed like I gotta find a team where
I can play I know they're gonna draft a
guy I'm gonna help this guy but I'm
gonna be the placeholder for a year
whether it's a year or half a season or
whatever it is and it's a difficult
thing because you know for me it was
like okay I've won over this team we're
playing well but you know there's always
that you know hourglass where the sand
is running out and you're going to be on
the bench and then you've got to support
the guy but that for me that was the
back half of my NFL career and a guy
like Andy Dalton uh trying to think of
other guys you know Mitch trubisky I
guess last year maybe is in that but
you've got to embrace it because you
know that that's your role and that's
what's going to help each franchise that
you play at talking to Ryan Fitzpatrick
Thursday night football analyst and uh
they'll be on Prime video this fall look
at Ryan Tannehill this is the second
consecutive year they've drafted
somebody who's supposed to take his job
now you got will Levis coming to town uh
how do you think that's going to play
out
foreign
you know that that's all going to be
contingent on how Ryan plays it really
is and unfortunately with Tennessee you
know they went from the number one seed
two years ago to falling off last year
to potentially falling off even more
this year just with more age and tread
on some of the veterans tires uh Ryan's
a really good quarterback but he's got
to be in the right situation
um and so you know he is going to be one
of those guys he's not going to be
looking over his shoulders going to go
out and play I think we saw with Malik
Willis last year he's not ready he he
wasn't ready to get out there when Ryan
got hurt play we'll leave us I think
we'll be in the same category so they
want Ryan to do well and succeed but it
is an interesting situation where they
keep drafting guys to replace him how
can tuatanga violoa play differently
to play safer
no that's a hard it's a hard question
because you know he the one thing that
he does really well is he can anticipate
get the ball out of his hands and so you
know that's something that's going to be
a real strength for him play calling is
the same way you can protect your
quarterback by some of the plays that
you're calling if you have a play down
the field and they're going to want to
throw the ball down the field of Tyreek
Hill they're going to want to throw it
down the hill down the field to Jalen
waddle that's where that San Francisco
offense the play action freezing
everybody at the line and buying
yourself a couple extra seconds moving
the pocket that's really going to help
too but he just you know I heard he's
taken Judo classes and learning how like
that that stuff that stuff really
doesn't matter it's going to be getting
the ball out of his hand it's going to
be maybe getting some guys up front to
protect him even better and just one
more year in that system of him
understanding where his issues are and
protection will be helpful for him how
good were you at hiding injuries
uh good you get good at it for sure and
part of it is you know you want to be
out there you have to be available for
your team and especially position I was
in uh you know I was never that
franchise guy so I had to be available
or else they were just going to move on
and go to the next guy but the other
part is you don't want the other team to
know especially you know playing
position a quarterback Where You're
vulnerable whether it's a rib injury or
an ankle injury or a shoulder injury you
don't want them to know to be able to go
after you
good to talk to you you enjoying TV you
got it figured out yeah yeah no still
figuring it out but I had a uh I had a
great first year I think
the same as with football it's it's a
team environment that you try to create
there's chemistry that you know we had
some great natural chemistry and then
there was some stuff we had to work on
but having great relationships off air
really does translate to good stuff on
the air I think that's what I figured
out in year one and I really like the
people I'm working with when I first
started at football night in America I
said we need to have a dinner every
Saturday night
just to talk
you know then you're you know you're
talking about your family or you're
talking football whatever it is it's
almost it gives you that built-in uh
kind of camaraderie and and and
therefore you're trusting each other on
the air and and I I did that with Tony
Dungy and Rodney Harrison and I thought
it made us better because we knew each
other as opposed to your you know
introducing yourself to Joe Thomas and
like Hey Joe how are you Ryan Howard and
we you know we did that I think somebody
very smart that was on the team
recognized the significance of that and
every Wednesday night we would fly into
the city we would have our dinners we
actually had a dinner in Denver that got
a little out of hand big Sushi Bill and
then uh you know we had to scale it back
a little bit
um after that but how much was the uh
Sushi let's guess the sushi bill I'll
just tell you over under so you're
taking yes okay and I'll tell you if
you're high or low
five thousand
so oh you're pretty you're pretty close
you're pretty close now I will say it
wasn't just the crew it was the
producers it was though we had the back
room it was 20 plus people so you're
probably a little low all right six
thousand maybe right around there I I
don't know the exact you know I'm paid
for it uh I'll say you know we've got
we've got the highest paid fifth round
pick of all time and Richard Sherman
we've got Andrew Whitworth who did
pretty well for himself Tony Gonzalez no
slouch especially with all the money
he's picking up for the commercials so
uh usually usually we just leave it with
big wit you know just because he's he's
such a force in L.A so well you are
working for the richest man in the world
and Jeff Bezos so
they paid a lot of money for the right
stuff so we're
good to talk to you Ryan and uh thanks
for joining us
all right thanks Dan that's Ryan
Fitzpatrick Thursday night football and
uh you can catch him the entire Thursday
night football crew on Prime video this
season